throughout history we've looked at men
as the stars of the boxing world
but these days some of the sports most
promising boxers come from a special
place in California
and they're all teenage girls i'm zoe
saldana from bc and i'm teaming up a
great big story to shine a light on
american lionex
excellence around the country
while boxing has long been a tradition
in the Central Valley of California it
wasn't until a few years ago that girls
were allowed to compete professionally
but once the sport was opened up to them
not only did girls start competing they
started winning a lot in 2017 four girls
from the Central Valley finished first
or second at the Junior Olympics once
you're in that ring is just you and your
opponent that's it I keep all my
aggressiveness inside the ring I'm a
beast inside three to be the number one
spot it takes a lot of hard work and
dedication but it's all worth it in the
end the one leading the pack is Sandra
toll our who at only 17 is ranked number
one in the nation in her weight class
she started boxing when she was only
eight years old with her father who
remains her coach to this day I trained
six days a week three trainings a day I
wake up in the morning and I go to
school I do my homework on the way to
boxing and I do it on the way back home
my biggest goal right now is to make it
till it fixed and get a gold medal for
me to make that goal possible every
single tournament that is coming up I
have to win it and gather up all my
points for my weight class and just keep
pushing her I've been coaching since
1992 and I've trained a lot of champions
and Sandra stands out
I remember when the sport of boxing was
just boys but I believe this new
generation of girls is gonna change it
competing professionally is expensive
and it's become a major obstacle for
many boxers in the Central Valley but
thanks to the community banding together
to raise funds to send these girls to
compete at the national level the
Central Valley has contributed to the
changing face of boxing
I believe it's because the way they're
raised they don't have much and they're
more willing to do whatever it takes to
move up makes them hungrier makes them
stronger willed to reach what they want
to get out of life I feel like the spots
are open tremendously right now in the
sport of female boxing I feel like it's
gonna end up getting equal to men boxing
you